oh right oh right
today's episode is brought to you by
gray block pizza gray block pizza at
1811 Pico Boulevard on the way to the
beach gray block get that hitter Denver
baby back from Denver and they call it
some people call it men ver men ver you
know like they got more men over there
but I saw a good uh I definitely saw a
decent gaggle of Mountain kitten you
know kind of just scheming about I saw a
lot of beautiful wah seem like a lot of
beautiful women over there I mean a lot
of we're at a distance could have been
um you know transvestites or wigged men
and there are a lot of wigged men out
there a lot of wonderful people visited
the shows a lot of Hill people a lot of
Mountain nurse you know you can um you
know you see a lot of people come down
they got different furs on them
different in Denver you don't know so
sometime you'll see that you'll you'll
be petting something and you'll think
it's a Great Dane and then it'll kind of
lift up and it's got a Starbucks then
it's some fella maybe some fella named
Randy or something he just had on the
fur you know you see a lot of uh
crouching Randy's or crouching Tigers
hitting Randy's you know you think
something it's like oh there's a sheep
and it's oh that's Vanessa you know she
was just bending down picking up
something she dropped her phone because
people we're exotic furs a lot of sheep
a lot of seal you'll see somebody
wearing seal fur seal skin so you
definitely have that wildness out there
a lot of neat people came out fat Trish
came out shout out fat Trish shout out I
met this guy who said that
- cigarette off of him in 2001 so that
was pretty cool my boy Eric came out
little Doyle gay Henry this dude who was
he just kept increasing the gay amount
as the night went on
you got those buddies you know you know
at 10 o'clock they they're you know
they're Brad Pitt at 10 p.m. and by 2:00
a.m. they [ __ ] ballbag Lance a lot
you know they just feel like whoa whoa
we really shift in here Ronnie
big Ronnie came out with that but with
those buck teeth respect and um I think
that was about everybody a lot of people
with Mountain asthma a lot of MAS the
mountain asthmatics and the air when you
get into Colorado the air has a little
bit of the air just feels thicker like
it's got shoulders on it like you just
that air it hit the sides of your lungs
that what you doing boy what you doing
you better be doing something oh wait
it's refreshing there's something
refreshing there and that's a gift a lot
of places do not have that but they have
it there and and what a beautiful group
of people - come on out and enjoy life
with when as Denver where the airs got
that that airs like it's wearing a
shoulder pads hit you you know that airs
got something in it it's got something
going on every breath you take you can
feel that it that that that that inhale
that that it's got a mother and a father
out there you know every you know when
you inhale the air out there in Colorado
you could feel the wind in the distance
looking for its baby that you just took
off the planet
it's Colorado man this is Colorado and
that's a native word I'm sure what does
it mean let me look it up right now
actually
shout outs all like three different
dudes came out that had a Trey Anastasio
tattoos on their back too and uh
Colorado is of Spanish origin meaning
color red the name was applied to the
Colorado River because of the red
sandstone style of the region and there
you go
so never too late to get some facts back
in Los Angeles back from the mountains
back from the I mean it's just really
just uh it's almost like you say you
opened up a refrigerator and all that's
inside of it is a bunch of nature and
there's a little mountain over there and
a mountain all the mountain is is a
mountain is just a bunch of land got
together and just said now what [ __ ]
you feel me you know saying a mountain
is just like a gang of land
it's basically ms-13 of dirt that's all
a mountain is brah you know a prairie
looks over at a mountain or you know
like a valley looks at a mountain it's
like damn these dudes are bullies that's
all it is but shout out everybody bruh
and uh and I'm back and we got a lot to
discuss and I'm happy to be here with
you and I really am gang let's go
[Music]
[Applause]
hi I'm Anna Mountain you're the red baby
say the free some Stevie starlight just
don't survive you and me it's on the
destination come on come on
[Music]
never too late to come over side slips
away so don't as
oh why must we wait when we're a
why must we wait when we are alive I say
it really I mean and that is Stevie
starlight right there and we'll put the
link to Stevie's music into his patreon
into you know he lent us that he allows
us to use that song and he was a guest
here early on the podcast and just so if
you haven't seen the stevie starlight
come over is that song the music video
is something exceptional in its it just
takes you back to a different time when
magic was running around through the
world and even it was barefoot good to
be here man and thank you Stevie for
that for that for that song it's never
too late to come over why must we wait
when we're alive I asked a good question
a good question I'll wait I'll wait on a
lot of stuff and I'm so indecisive my
way I always wait I don't know who I
don't know if I there you know that's
why I always do that's my first my first
thought is I mmm
maybe next time he do it next year I'll
go skiing next year that's what I always
tell myself you know and then here it's
been a couple years since I've been
skiing or snowboarding or even just fall
fell down a hill with ice on it or even
just slipped in a damn parking lot you
know amongst a group of young men that
were mentally unwell
you know my grandmother when I was young
I would go up to my grandmother's in Nam
and my mom she made me take we had a uh
we had a cat that lived in our
neighborhood and the lady we'd be gone
in the summer that we watched her cat
this cat named quagmire was his name and
so when I went up to my grandmother's in
the summer my mom would send that cat up
there with me
because my grandmother loved cats and
she really she loved cats more than she
loved me really
she pet that cat and and I just sit on
the other side of the room just kind of
you know just looking at my hands or
just maybe I'd have like a little maybe
a chocolate in my pocket or a marble or
something I'd get it out and look at it
and put it back in and my grandmother be
over there just stroking Quagmire's back
dude I'm her one time actually me and
this other boy we went over to the park
and I mean we could have been homosexual
I don't know I think we're just children
but we just ended up petting each
other's backs like it my grandmother did
with that cat with quagmire that cat but
that's the romance of being young you
know is that things can happen in that
you know and you just I don't know what
the hell I'm talking about but I mean I
almost did and then I just you know you
just don't know good to be here just got
back to Los Angeles five nice shows in
Denver and a lot of a lot of wonderful
people came out I see a lot of babies
you know chris d'elia is a comedian you
guys may have heard of him he's a
comedian he's uh he also used to do a
lot of like male modeling I think in
like Estonia or kind of like a war-torn
area and I'm seeing a lot of uh you know
a lot of people life rips and these
dents I uh you know these sweaters
wearing dents
and everything would it you know or and
people wearing them to the shows and so
it's nice to see just that a lot of
these you know babies are coming over
from from their stepdaddy's house and
coming back to Papa's layer so it is
just really nice welcome home welcome
home it's never too late to come over is
it
but yeah saw a lot of those uh a lot of
life's rips and dents where's this
weekend just a great time great time out
there you know they had um I got back to
Los Angeles and at the airport I landed
and I was walking and I thought wow the
feeling in the air is just different and
it's because I mean I knew a meet to me
it was obvious it was just booked it was
because of the Kobe Bryant death and I
was like oh wow this is you know I could
just feel it in there it was just a
little bit just somber you know and I
think it's just such a reminder to
everyone I mean to me it was such a
reminder of just just what a rare gift
it is that we're running around with you
know what a rare you know what an
opportunity that we have even if
sometimes we don't be in it and I'm not
saying I noticed this all the time or
that I'm evil able to access it but
there's some reason why when you know
when a deathlike of Kobe Bryant you know
somebody of that magnitude I mean he was
you know I was more of a Michael Jordan
guy but I've always had I've always been
astonished by how beloved Kobe Bryant is
and was I mean one of my college
roommates Jerome this huge Kobe Bryant
fan always was you knowing that we were
in Louisiana um you know just the Asian
pick an Asian
and they are a Kobe Bryant fan Latinos
no bro you throw a Kobe Bryant Jersey
back across the border at least probably
1100 people who are climbing over will
immediately go back the other way -
somebody's gonna try to get it and I
don't mean that in any sort of racial
way I'm just saying that Kobe has a huge
Mexican fan base you know you always see
Mickey McConnell guys you'll see him in
every era in the parking lots man
shooting balance esto at night
oh shoot the six pointer shoot the six
point erector you know wearing Dickies
bra SEVIS you'll have nine guys on one
team and they're playing another group
of guys that probably has five guys or
six or 14 guys on the team everybody has
on a Kobe Bryant hers he and one dude
there's one referee he has no shirt on
and somebody spray-painted the number 24
on his back or a veinticuatro somebody
wrote that across his chest but yeah
just so beloved man I mean that man was
just beloved and just the tragedy and
you just uh you know since I wasn't a
fan it was it was tough for me to relate
on a way of like oh man this basketball
player but once you know there was more
information about how his daughter was
with him and it was very easy for me to
relate on a level of uh of just man to
be in that situation to be with your
daughter to be just to feel so helpless
you know probably and just what a gift
you know and it just makes you walking
around it adds a thicker weight to my
blood you know it's funny it's like when
somebody who seems to be carrying a lot
of weight in the world because Kobe you
know Kobe
I mean loved and hated it seemed liked
by a lot of hated in the sense that
people hated playing and people hated
maybe being on his team like he was just
probably too intense maybe for some
people but always like we seem to be
respected you know I don't know just
kind of just uh just a so it was
interesting coming back to Los Angeles
and get in here and being like oh this
is you know the ground floor of the
place that lost him yeah just you know
real heartbreaking heartbreaking and it
it just adds a heavier weight because
whenever there's someone's you know is
when you have like somebody like that
that's such a hero and they're gone then
suddenly all of that weight they were
carry and all the whatever they were
holding up all of that has to settle
back in other people's shoulders in
other places in the world you know all
the people they were holding up
emotionally family members financially
all of that all has to settle you know
it all has to find other places to rest
comfortably and you can just feel that
unrest in the air out here and it's so
scary is so scary to think it's scary to
think about death but then it's even
scarier to when the feeling there's this
moment where the thought turns like
turns on this or fog or goes over it's
like this thought the thought turns into
a feeling in your body and that's when
for me I can always have to quit
thinking about that sort of thing or it
just becomes this - it's too much for
your soul to comprehend
you know the idea of going on to
somewhere else and and also how be you
know I mean it's
you know I believe that there's
something beyond this and I believe that
what a wild adventure to walk into the
afterlife with your daughter or with
your father
and I don't mean that in like a morose
way I just mean that in a way of uh you
know that I always believe that there's
some bigger plane going on that we can't
see and and I wait you know I will hope
that you know one day when I go on that
I mean what a gift it would be to go
with somebody that you already love or
that has love for you or just to wander
out into this into this new feeling of
yourself I mean when you when you leave
here man when you I bet you kind of just
immediately like void through into this
other world this other you know it could
be water it could be something that we
don't even know some viscous type of
deal could be made out of sprinkles I
don't know it could be some whatever
chasm we move into just to feel your
body transposed from one into the next
but to have your in your hand at the
hand of somebody else that knowing
you're not alone you know that's got to
be something nice we had uh in the
comedy world there's a comedian Ari
Shaffir and he you know he had some wild
thoughts on the Kobe situation and some
people were not excited about that I
want to play this video that Ari Shaffir
put out you can if you haven't already
heard it and this was after the plane
the helicopter crash homeward it's
always a lot of like hey pay the
so as much terrible stories every once
in a while there's a good story good
story come down guy who got away with
rape got his today
Kobe Bryant is a God I'm here in
Charlotte the Homewood team that
originally drafted him maybe wouldn't
break that chick in Denver if even if it
stayed in Charlotte with the Hornets
anyway the point is it's like people it
that didn't go over well well I mean
I'll put that right there it just didn't
go over well with people Ari also had a
tweet Kobe Bryant died 23 years too late
today he got away with rape because all
the Hollywood liberals who attack comedy
enjoy rooting for the Lakers more than
they dislike rape Big Ups to the hero
who forgot to gas up his chopper I hate
the Lakers what a great day hashtag [ __ ]
the Lakers there's a lot to unpack I
think and all of that you know I mean I
personally I went through a gamut of
like thoughts and emotions but with it
just like a regular dude man like and
it's funny because the way I thought
yesterday about it and the way I thought
today about it have adjusted I mean at
first I was just like man this is this
crazy like is it is he joking is he
serious you know there were children
killed children that died and so you
know it's just that's too much to joke
about it's too much you know I was like
it's just it's too much
there was also part of me that was like
you know I I had the thought to whenever
you know when a lot of people were you
know really lamenting Kobe right I was
like yeah did he rape someone you know
that came into my head I could never I
couldn't remember exactly how that had
played out in the court system and stuff
but here's a guy that was accused of
that in at net you know he went to court
and then there was a settlement so those
are just things that kind of popped into
my head you know and then once you I
learned that his daughters and you know
there was more people involved his
daughter and other young people and just
I mean it just uh for me it landed in a
hole in its whole different spot now for
Ari Shaffir I mean he's an edgy comedian
that's his whole thing you know he's uh
he is he's harsh he is vulgar at times
maybe
I mean I'm and I'm not you know I'm not
like denouncing Ari I don't believe in
this canceled culture stuff at first I
was just shocked I was like wow what is
he trying to get attention is he you
know is he the video it had like he has
like a little bit of a smirk in it so it
came if for sure was gonna make people
irate I mean it was just there was too
much he was doing it in front of a
picture of other basketball players in
Charlotte there's just so many elements
that make it bad or that make it tough
to digest let me say that especially on
a day when so many people when he was
just beloved by so many people and then
it's interesting because then today like
last night I'm looking at different
tweets like Michael Rapaport took took
Ari to the woodshed really he he goes I
want people to see who this piece of
[ __ ] is I think it's disgusting Rapoport
went in hard on the dude he said meet
comedian Ari Shaffir this is a
professional comedian hashtag Ari
Shaffir at Ari Shaffir he was not stoked
or he got also referred to as a white
supremacist their racist piece of [ __ ]
you know people went at him he I mean it
was funny how it was interesting it was
interesting to see online how the
hatred online just started to build and
turn over itself and how it got people
called Joe Rogan into it like just how
it just kind of became this um like an
avalanche like a hay bale that's
somebody pushed over a levee you know it
became this building thing this Manama
noble snowman and then today I'm like
well I mean if you it's tough because
you've you have to if you want to
believe in freedom of speech which we
have to have it then then some people
are just gonna say what they want to say
you know I don't know our he's intent on
this I don't know if he's trying to sell
tickets and Charlotte I don't know I
don't know I mean people also say this
is a character that he does where he
does a lot about like when people die
he'll make like a funny video or a funny
tweet or make a tweet trying to make
light of a situation under a certain
like dirty character that he has
honestly it's interesting as if already
walked into the room yesterday if he
walked in I'd have been like dude what
the [ __ ] what's going on and I think
that's how most people would have been
if he in human in human form would have
walked into the room after you had seen
the video and read this tweet but online
it's like this other thing you can be
you know people are like Santa I'm gonna
knock him out right when I see him at
the Comedy Store
people are saying black people go get
this guy there was definitely a lot of
black racial hatred towards him and from
everybody I mean it was from all
directions and it wasn't just black for
sure but you know there was like some
you know black Twitter can be wild but
yeah I just thought it definitely it was
just it was some rough timing
it was definitely rough timing but that
had to be what he's going for I mean
that's what he's doing there's some
people that you know there's like
whatever that sign is the insult dog
remember that guy the little dog the
puppet and then there's Ari but for him
the death wish Doberman
you know I mean he he wanted all the
smoke and he got it man he definitely
got it so my I just end up thinking that
if we're gonna people can say what they
want and they should be able to say what
they want and the repercussions of it
are Pete other people are gonna react
the way they want to you can't say that
people can't say something even if you
don't agree with it I can't say oh he
can't say that
and I don't think that Twitter or any
you know any of these platforms should
be able to say someone can't say
something the way you learn what works
and what doesn't is by trying things out
now I don't think that I mean I don't
know if this is him trying some I mean
I'm not I'm not saying any of that but
I'm just saying you have to still have
that you know now he know he knows how
people feel and that you know people get
to react the way they want to to certain
things that's what it's all about
but I just think it was interesting when
I thought to myself okay well he's
online saying this this stuff but if you
see him in person what I would probably
be a lot more human like I would you
know I'm thinking I would be like Oh
what do what was going on man geez I
think you will frickin you know is it
tough to take a nap because so many
because your phone is just burning with
the hatred of so many people towards you
I guess that's my thoughts on it
you know you say what you want and you
can suffer the repercussions of it or
you can see how people other people feel
about it but to say this guy screw then
you just don't go by it then don't buy a
ticket if you live you don't want to see
him
now some people who's into the dark arts
and stuff they're gonna really thrive on
this they might buy a new kitten or
something name it Ari Shaffir I mean I
don't think Michael Rapaport is gonna
buy one but you know just like anybody
he can say what he wants to and then
people get to react to it and then
that's how you you get to say what you
want back so that's really my thoughts
on it I mean I just the part that scares
me is when they start saying that Oh
take this guy's a count away and take
this sort of thing like that just that
because that's never gonna help anything
people still have to be able to say what
they want that's how you learn you know
that's how you learn but man that was a
ballsy [ __ ] move huh it was just a
ballsy just like I don't know if I could
take all that heat online I just don't
know if I could take all that heat I got
to tell you right now um that Beck's
is what I put on a lot I'll put some on
right now bro bad boys what you want I
got on these Beck Shea's baby I got on
these Beck shades and dude these are
nice some of them if you want that
polarization you want to make the world
feel like it's really a you know you're
in a class of your own then Beck's
sunglasses can do that you want to take
care of your eyes you want to look
classy suave you want to walk in and
just me and see the ladies go straight
in a cardiac arrest
then you need Beck's with the Sun the
way it is now with either global warming
or just extra Sun you need sunglasses
that won't you know that aren't gonna
let that heat get through and laser you
down Beck's
sunglasses are badass polarized
sunglasses and that are tough and clear
as hell I mean these things are just
dude and they have that you almost so
you know different payers did look make
it look different ways
suave cool you need to look like a ninja
on a wedding cake one of the payers make
you look like a damn ninja at a bakery
support this podcast you're gonna buy
sunglasses buy them from Bex Beck's
sunglasses are light rugged polarized
made with luxury materials by the finest
craftsmanship in the world Beck's
sunglasses perform under the harshest
conditions you could read Ari Shaffir
tweets in these buy your sunglasses from
Beck's sunglasses calm that's B e^x
sunglasses calm and use code Theo for
20% off your entire order bra Beck's
sunglasses BX sunglasses dot-com and use
code th EO for 20% off your entire order
summer is coming up get Beck see Beck
sunglasses calm use code Theo let's get
him a couple questions here we had a
call let me hit the hotline as always
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three and uh r.i.p Kobe Bryant I
couldn't remember
you know Michael Landon I've always been
a huge fan I mean he was basically the
white James Brown and we need died man
from cigarettes hmm
it felt like somebody just reached
inside of my nuts and just took one of
my nuts out they felt like a lot it felt
like a lot
I couldn't remember you know when I was
young in Covington Louisiana they had a
boy we were playing basketball and this
tall beautiful young black gentleman
named Ricardo Jordan man he had a smile
looked like somebody had just hid two
pianos in his mouth man he just had a
big big big smile his smile must have
been damn nine inches long he's about 63
or 64 and the 8th grade I mean the kid
was humongous
and we're playing a basketball game and
he fell on the court and just and never
he didn't hit his head or anything he
just had like a seizure just his heart
you know one of those children that
their body was so big and their heart
just couldn't do the magic for it and he
left and then I mean and that was it you
know they never brought him back to
consciousness and man it was God that
hurt so much when I was young because to
see a to have a child you know just
someone like I was a child
you know the atoms that were inside of
him were the same atoms that were inside
of me they were you know nervous excited
you know
hopeful energy and to see that energy
just not have the form it had inside of
his body anymore man that was so scary
as a child anyway I don't mean to harp
on you know getting I'm just trying to
think of an of a tragedy that happened
on a national level I don't know I don't
know maybe I was there a sports hero
that I can't think of a differently what
did you guys think of the Ari Shaffir
scenario you know if you heard anything
about it or read about it or or even if
you just heard about it at all what do
you think about you know when there's an
instance like that you know people
sharing how they feel and if it's too
much I mean people can do whatever they
want and you can react to it however you
want let's
let's take a call here we go right here
yo yo
this is Kenny Martinez I work what's up
Kenny was one of the guys I got to see
you this past weekend in Denver
I just want to call and tell you thank
you man you killed it I literally was
gang [ __ ] baby home word I like I was
like the first ten minutes into Dorset I
was like if he doesn't stop them and I
have a heart attack or something cuz I
couldn't breathe that's what I'm talking
about boy they call me that body bag or
dog you know what I'm saying dude you
get a body bag you get a body bag you
get a body bag cuz when the audience has
come baby I'm sending them home in a
to-go box daddy that's who I am
okay I'm that sweet patate baby I'm that
stage yam daddy I'm that carbo hydrate
son I'm that drip-drop gang let's go my
stomach might have hurt so bad from
laughing myself and my girl were there
and we were both packing up it was funny
as hell I just want to call and tell you
one thanks for the show and the show was
great my girl I said got those tickets
for us there's knows how big of a fan I
am of yours and I was telling her one
day that's like a steel bombs coming to
Denver just announced and I swear to you
not even two minutes later I was sitting
in the kitchen she's a monster I just
bought us tickets VIP tickets we're
gonna get to meet him so well she sounds
like a sweet lady man and I'm very
grateful that you guys came out and and
we're a part of my weekend as well so
you guys take care of it air and stay
off that altitude
a lot of you get up on that altitude
that's free dope that's free dope out
there people you know you they are yard
you get off the plane you 2,000 feet up
in the air in Denver look what the hell
I'm used to a plane takes you all the
way to the ground
oh hey plane uh-huh
you dropped me off at about uh 1,100
feet okay I know we're at the airport
but you built this whole city on the top
of a hill so that altitude is wild I
mean you can't even in strange stuff you
can't even get a spoon into a bowl of
soup just you're like damn what supposed
to be cream of mushroom thank you for
coming out ma'am onward let's take
another call here here we go what a deal
this is cross from Oklahoma I work to
see your show at the Tower Theatre in a
year and it was amazing oh thank you
brother yeah in Oklahoma man's beautiful
area over there and one of the managers
at The Comedy Store this gentleman
Curtis Nelson is an Oklahoman and he's
uh probably one of the top 60 or 70
decent men I've known Oh word
and I'm sitting here watching this past
weekend at my house I'm just curious uh
you give a lot of credit to your higher
power and to be honest you sound like
with the way you talk you sound like
you're uh you believe in Jesus you
believe in God so I'll just wondering
how come you don't say God whatever you
say your higher power or do you just not
believe in necessary of God and that
there is just a higher power
anyways men keep doing you getting
better love you
gang game bro love you back Playboy uh
you know sometime I say higher power um
you know my god isn't like a real name
maniac some gods is a real name maniac
you know call me it is call me they call
me Henry you know but um you know I
believe in God man and I know I know
some people don't that's fine with me
you know I think I ever God is a
personal choice and for me I think I
need a God I don't do the best job of
believing in him sometimes I know a lot
of times I'd say I do my home will but
you know I just think it's rip it's it's
taking a chance man it's taking a chance
to believe in God you know to say that
there's something out there
because sometimes in my brain I can't I
don't want the best for myself you know
as sad as that is to say or as hard as
that is to say sometimes uh you know
sometimes I don't want you know I'll
just be have either to be feeling
depressed or it's not good or just I
don't know or just you know sometimes I
just don't I don't want the best for
myself in some ways I can't even explain
it really mm-hmm
sometimes it's easier for me to expect
not good things to happen because then
I'll be able to say oh I told you so you
know it's easier for me to expect you
know to try and like I don't know I
don't know examine the know what I'm
trying to say just sometimes it's hard
for me it's been hard for me this past
year to really connect to some of my
feelings um but I believe in I believe
in God man I believe in a higher power
and it's a God of my understanding and I
believe that you can have your own
relationship with God I believe that and
for me I'm glad that it's there because
it's fascinating to me sometimes that
even when I don't care about you know
sometimes when I don't care about myself
I don't have the strength or the you
know it's it's it's it's amazing to
believe that somebody does you know that
something out there really does want the
best for me and that to me that's God
you know I believe that God wants the
best for me and that's scary to think
really because a lot of my life you know
I think growing up and you know just in
my and I'm not and look I'm not feeling
sorry for myself right now P I'm not
being hard on myself I'm just trying to
share my feelings and talk on something
I'm not having self-pity right now I'm
just trying to share my feelings you
know well even in believing in a higher
power is scary I think it's risky
and most of my life you know I felt like
God like God didn't care I felt like God
didn't care about me if I'm real honest
or it was just way easier for me to
admit to myself to say to myself Oh God
doesn't love me you know God doesn't
love me but the older I get and just the
more like just little blessings that I
see you know it could be a smile and
somebody you know it could be somebody
answering the phone when I called them
somebody who I don't even think I don't
know man it can be it could be times
even when I don't want to spend time
with someone and I choose to because I
know it's what they need
I'm not trying to say that in a selfish
way but just you know I don't even want
to make the choice be like aw to do that
and and then something will come over me
and say oh I know I need to do this on
it's not about me yeah that and there's
just too many of those coincidences
eventually where you know I just have to
admit that that there's I believe that
there's something out there that wants
to see me that wants me to know that it
loves me
[Music]
and that's you know that's you know cuz
a lot of my life I felt either unloved
or unlovable you know or uh or I just
felt like I didn't care about others I
don't know I just I don't know man a lot
of it's a new relationship for me and
it's one that I'm trying to just try my
best with um and I don't have any of the
answers but for me to believe that
something that doesn't even know me
really has always loved me like really
loved me man like loved me no matter
what I did you know that's to me that's
that's pretty that's that's a power
stronger than anything I could do so I
kind of don't know what I'm talking
about but I say my god because I think
that different people have different
gods different people have their own
gods I don't you know I don't I don't
get into God fights that's not my thing
[Music]
you know and and also I don't know man I
have no idea but I appreciate you
calling and asking and uh and be good
bro be good out there you know
[Music]
you know sometimes it's just so it's so
hard for me sometimes to love somebody
else you know I'll use like I'll use my
care like my ability to care about
others I use that in relationships you
know I've used that before it's like a
weapon sometimes like I'll keep like
I've kept my care away from somebody
like even though maybe I love somebody I
kept my care I kept you know I like I
used my care as like a weapon like oh
you know you know I just I would love to
one day be able to be in a place where
my love and care for others isn't on a
like a scale type of basis you know
isn't on is it on any type of exchange
basis at all you know or that I don't
like I mean I would just I would love to
be able to you know I think I I think
that one day I would like to be able to
love somebody no matter what you know
cuz that's how you know that's how
that's how you know that's how I would
like to be loved probably by someone and
I've never really been able to do that
[ __ ] I never really have felt examples
of that and stuff growing up and look
I'm not having self-pity I'm not [ __ ]
down in the dumps right now I'm not
being hard on myself I'm just trying to
share things that I think are things
that I'm thinking about you know I know
I'm hard on myself a lot people always
come up to me to show it man don't be
throwing yourself I know I am you know
sometimes it's the only way that I've
ever known to be dog
no better time to talk to you about blue
shoe look I'll tell you this man I was
talking to somebody this weekend and
they were saying hey boy what about them
deep Hills you know what about the meat
pellets daddy you riding with him are
you were you dying with him son cuz I'm
ride or die I'll tell you this blue Chu
is a legitimate wiener upper that's
right remember the days when you were
ready to go remember that oh I remember
I'd hear two cars uh you know crash into
each other down the street and I'd get
an erection huh
I hear I'd hear somebody throw a
dodgeball and just bounce off a fat kids
stomach and I get just straight up son
I get that Indiana bones and my whip you
feel me now you can increase your
performance and get that extra
confidence in bed blue Chu calm that's
blue like the color blue and choose CH e
W calm the first chewable with the same
fda-approved active ingredients as
Viagra and Cialis look support the
podcast get your dick well try something
new you got a husband you got a lover
you got a gay lover do something right
women take them you go order them get
your tits all hard and stuff do
something special get your get your toes
you can't even bend them do too blue
choose and you can't even freaking move
you can't even bend your knees and your
legs anymore they can have to put you in
the back of the van you know you can
take them any time day or night even on
a full stomach
yeah dude now I would not suggest
hanging on a full stomach
Kiefer's I say wait 30 minutes you know
sex is like swimming really for your
wiener if you could benefit from more
confidence where it counts blue chew is
the fast and easy way to enhance your
performance and right now we got a
special deal for our listeners visit
blue ChiCom and get your first shipment
free when you use our special promo code
Theo just pay $5
that's easy guys try it out they work
I've taken mile tell you the first time
I had when I was somewhere performing I
think may be out there and Laramie
somewhere out there and um you know
could have been a will a met over there
maybe in South Washington and a man gave
me one after the show he said hey B hey
daddy get that you know treat your hand
to a nice night and I did it and I had
and it was great
again that's BL you eche w.com promo
code Theo and try it for free blue chew
is the better cheaper faster choice and
thank you guys for sponsoring the
podcast blue chew and young fellas get
that meet rocky baby gang some dates I
have coming up I will be at Las Vegas
this January 31st and February 1st this
weekend I will be at the Hollywood
improv February 6 the sold-out Oroville
casino February 15th you want to do
something nice for Valentine's Day
weekend quit thinking about it don't go
out on the 14th go out on the 15th to
make it easier less traffic and come and
see you boy then I'll be in Red Bank New
Jersey on the 27th and the theater MGM
National Harbor on February 28th we may
be adding a show in Richmond or in
Virginia Beach I'm not sure also be I'll
be in Toronto from February 20th to the
22nd and we may be adding a show there
as well let's take a few more few more
calls this came in from patreon Kim
chicken's ass acute named Kim chickens
Casey or SF you know I'm going with
Kansas City boy and shout out to my
Franklin Washington who lives over there
in San Francisco and and I respect the
bay I like what they're doing over there
but you know I'm going with Kansas City
they've been through it all you know
they got a I mean they play outdoors for
that reason alone they play outdoors the
Chiefs
the Chiefs baby Christian Okoye yay all
right uh who else did they have dude
[ __ ] I don't remember bro I'm going for
the Chiefs there you go Kim chickens
Jordy Tornai should breeze hang it up
breeze is the bee's knees but he's
getting up there what do you think gang
you know Jordy has such a tough one
because it's interesting at a certain
point the VAT uh it's like what do you
owe the player as a city and as a
franchise you know I didn't like the one
thing I did not like about Kobe Bryant
as a player was when when he went on
that last season and he went to all the
different places and he just kind of you
know like it just seemed like what's
going on here they tanked our whole
season they're not really gonna do
anything you know he's kind of hobbled
he's just it's just it was almost like
the whole season was just a parade for
him to go around and have one last
season but it makes you wonder did the
franchise oh that to him did basketball
oh that to him you know what do we as
fans you do you just sit for a season
and watch somebody who you may not think
can be their best I mean I think the
Saints could have won this year they
could have done better I mean all they
had to do is have a little bit better
offensive line and then if they give him
the ball latavius Murray heading there
into the playoffs but they didn't do
that
so is it breezed Muni through for I
think 72% past completion percentage
this year yeah I don't I don't know if
you're gonna do better with Taysom Hill
if you're gonna do better with Teddy
Bridgewater I don't think you are but
when team starts to realize he can't
throw deep I think it's gonna be up to
him I wonder him going to the Pro Bowl
and seeing all the athleticism of those
other guys out there how that if that
makes him feel some type of way you know
spend in a summer with his children and
watching his boys play
flag football like you see on his
Instagram does that settle in him in a
place where like oh this is what's more
important or you know I've had a great
run or I don't believe he's the type of
man that would come back unless he
really felt like he was gonna add a lot
of value he strikes me that way as a
human but also what do I know brother
what else do we have here let's take
another more Matt Nichols what's one way
you suggest a person can better
themselves you're constantly listening
to the hotline or reading the listeners
questions does this help in evaluating
yourself and evolving emotionally you
know one thing man
that I've realized is that it's a
constant battle it's a constant battle
and by listening to different people's
calls and reading the emails and
messages the one thing that's heavy and
me a lot of times is they're just that
reminder you know what I don't want to
do something but I don't want to do that
I don't want to you know go feed that
animal to do this or do that or clean
out the gutter you know when I don't
want to you know you know when I don't
want to go get the frisbee and throw it
to the neighbor or whatever when I don't
want to go for a run or I don't want to
take care of myself I think man is a lot
you know I have to do it you know
there's a lot of people that night that
are counting me or anything there's a
lot of people that I'm trying I try to
mother I try to say hey you can do it so
that kind of reminds me it's just like
having constant reminders yeah and
that's why I say this this whole shows a
lot of times like a give-and-take you
know we just kind of keep sharing it
back and forth and sometimes you guys
you know sometimes somebody needs some
support sometimes I need some support
and we all just sometimes you know
because we're all just so much the same
really so one thing that that keeps you
motivated and going a lot of times is
trying some contrary action I'm gonna
got home today from Denver dude I got
off the plane I did lat I got home I did
not want to go for a run
and instead of just living in that I
said whoop put on my shoes I'm going
dude
and when you don't want to it's hard but
then it gets easy and then that's where
you start to break down that change that
muscle if I don't want to because that's
just a feeling because really I do want
to really I do
[Music]
Alaskan ROC vodka said what plans have
you got for patreon this year that's a
great question man well for one you know
try to answer more patreon questions try
to put out some patron specific episodes
or else we'll probably do a couple
guests that it will just be on patreon
and maybe we do it behind the scenes of
some moments that you don't get to see
in other places maybe uh some outreach
calls or something like that if you guys
have certain suggestions let me know I
would love to do something special for
patreon at the at the shows when we're
at the shows all right let's take
another call right here here we go
what's up Flint what's up big Jimbo out
there in Flint boy that freaking that uh
that mud sipper baby that dirty water
bad boy that backsplash hit our gang
really what I want to do is just thank
you man for the past three episodes that
you had a guest on you've made of Flint
Michigan Wilson you know and every
morning I wake up I'm poundin the Lord
beg him to you know let me live the life
that I lived and I have some to show me
a sign that I am living in the past that
I'm meant to walk down hmm I asked me to
show me a sign it sure enough without
sale I've been teaching the word for
treating around picking up the old
lady's yell with the Lord or reference
the finish Gideon and that's it I know
I'm doing supposed to be doing living
the life that I'm good to be living but
I just want to say you know I really
appreciate it
if you ever want to get into the
nitty-gritty about the city Flint
Michigan just give me a shout that
sounds good I appreciate that Jimbo you
know and I look bro I grew up with my
boy Daniel dude and you know him bro I
mean he could do all kind of wild stuff
you know he's the kind of dude he used
to have some of the older men he'd have
him take hits off of cigarettes and blow
the smoke into his ear and then he would
open up his eyes and they would be pitch
black and I don't know how he did it and
he would take speaking of Flint Michigan
he would take that hot hose hit baby you
know and that's when you put your mouth
on the hose and then you go have
somebody turn it on while it's been
sitting there all spring just bacon in
the Sun and you get that you get that
first freakin mmm you get that first -
brah right in your throat just
everything it's in natto just the past
and the present and all the risks and
things that just was in your house and
flowed right out and just stuck in that
in that green hose brah and sometimes he
would even go that light green hose that
was the shady when remember that when
that light green hose but your boy
Daniel breaks his own choices you know
when he got that hot hose hit brother
you know so every time I hear about
flint you guys over there drinking dirty
water and you know making soup and in
the bathtub and all of that you guys
doing wild [ __ ] I mean it's like damn
Noah's Ark over there you know you guys
over there drinking bug and you know
soil kool-aid and all of that and being
wild and being naughty I think it's
beautiful bro you know it's like our own
little Nairobi right here and uh in
Michigan man shout out gang bro be safe
out there Jimbo you an old lady bro gang
let's take a call right here maybe this
will be our last one today I do not know
paso alejandro me amigo gracias por el
telephone Oh telephone oh yeah Maura I
miss telephone call so I'll let you know
man I'm a huge fan and every time I see
your pod cos you know there's a there's
always people calling but they're don't
there's usually they're always white
there's always white guys a few here I
don't like a hundred people is like four
of them are black you know and let you
know that a lot of us are kind of
[ __ ] love you too bro
[ __ ] the wild brah do all men say
Papa gang game and I [ __ ] love you
think thank you thank you man a sweetie
to say dude you know I noticed a lot of
similarity I notice a lot of things in
in Hispanic culture that I wrote that
really are attractive to me man in my
heart you know in me Carrasco you know
Latinos like family is really really
important you know hard work you know
some of the hardest working women that I
see man it's really I mean this brings a
tear to my eye almost said uh especially
in Los Angeles in this area are Mexican
women and I'm not look I'm not saying
there's not hard-working white women out
there I'm not did I'm not saying any of
that I'm not saying there's not
hard-working black women out there you
know I just see a lot of actually it
could be any hard-working woman you know
but you see a lot of uh you know you
just see I see a lot in Los Angeles I
see a lot of those mothers you know
getting off the bus with their kids or
you know the husband getting and
dropping them off real early you know
because they're one vehicle families you
know I just see a lot of love dude
there's a lot of love in that community
and
and I see it man you know and I think
when somebody from another like
ethnicity or culture like shows you love
I mean it's crazy it just shows the
power of love man because to think that
somebody's like oh man dude I support
you you know you don't look like me you
know you don't sound like me but I
believe that you know our heart is the
same color you know yeah I don't know
that there's just something I don't know
a lot of those women they just remind me
of when I see a lot of Latino women out
there working hard at reminds me of my
mother you know or maybe a mother that I
wish I had I don't know man I just
there's something about yeah I don't
know I just I love the culture man I
love the language my father when I was
young you know he would talk to some of
his friends and they would sit there and
talk in Spanish and I just and he was so
happy man I think that was one of the
times that really my I guess I hadn't
thought about really that much but that
was one of the time my father was just
so happy when he was talking in Spanish
and just laughing you know and he liked
to show people that he could talk in
Spanish you know just because he grew up
in Central America till he was 12 and
then he moved but I think he just always
had that you know we always just had it
in his heart so yeah I don't know maybe
some of it's an homage to my father you
know I uh but uh if anything all this
does is it made me want to work harder
to learn Spanish but thank you for the
nice message dude thank you for the nice
message bro you know what I'm saying
dude okay
uh let's take another call right here
man we'll take one more gang [ __ ] yo Co
this is Jeff aka little water socks
what's up water socks dude and is that I
don't know if that's Native American or
not
but let me hear more Jeffrey calling
from toy Florida first my daughter and I
were talking and said we're gonna be
pretty mad if you don't come back as
uncle baby Billie's son in the second
season of righteous gemstones I think
I'd be fired well look one thing you can
do is go send a DM to Jody Hill on
Instagram and tell them that I'm ready
okay because I am long word but uh yes
I'm 36 I rap and sometimes I feel like
maybe it's not as cool to be a 36 year
old rapper as it would be to be like in
a band or maybe gonna stand up you know
comic just wondering it is that weird
like what do you guys think of it is it
weird to be quote-unquote unsuccessful
rapper still rapping I love it I'm gonna
have a good job I make cheerleading
music actually as it for a living but
you know I see four kids and all that
but you know I have this little passion
on the side doesn't get too much love
but put that [ __ ] out bro put that [ __ ]
out put on a mask put on a you know put
some horns on the side of your head do a
rap do an album dude you know you're
making cheerleading on the side if you
got to do that get that money get that
shoot the three
shoot shoot the three money but then cut
that [ __ ] at night bruh
put the kiddo to bed son and drop that
dark magic dog you know what I'm saying
sound proof that little [ __ ] crib and
drop that dark magic because guess what
ain't you know what ain't suavi bruh
a 37 year old rapper 38 year old 51 year
old Franklin over there dropping albums
[ __ ] ain't doing
Frankie okay so 36 you on that cusp
daddy you on that cusp bro because let
me tell you this man drop it now drop
that heat now because at 37 38 people
just gonna think he's some kind of wild
Wigga bruh to be honest with you no
disrespect every man who's 36 thinks
they're a rapper so show that work bro
get something out there get the children
out there due to child due to
cheerleaders get something out there do
that [ __ ] boys to men remix it Blind
Melon bro you know what I'm saying acid
bath do something sexy son but not
around the children do your own [ __ ] put
a mask on you know I'm saying drink a
bunch of glitter and vomit on your
cousin dog and then put on the laser
lights boy but do something bro cuz that
the further you get 3738 you're just
gonna be like kind of a wig a type of
dude 4050 bro 50 years old you a rapper
dude you're gonna be living outside of a
gas station papa so I respect the hustle
bruh but I want to see that muscle daddy
gang [ __ ] oh thank you guys so much we
got one more call here yeah brother and
he's recently come across some meat that
my sister gives him and she's actually a
truck driver oh yeah I know what she's
talking about dude that's a just family
meat man homework and so she gets a lot
of exotic meat throughout the Midwest
and she off was a couple of couple of
pounds of ostrich my brother and you
know he's been eating everyday and he
it's kind of like he that it's kind of
like he is it's a picture of everyday is
just a little weird and I'm wondering
what's your idea of that man like truck
driver Wow burden me you know do you
think it might be going to his brain a
little bit
anyways man thanks man I hope you're
doing good
thanks brother back at you man oh I
think if you have a little bit of
stretch butter ain't nothing wrong with
you you know there ain't nothing wrong
you wake up in the morning have a couple
eggs and a hit a stretch you know not
everybody gets to have ostrich so maybe
you know you should you know your
brother's lucky to have that delicacy
baby you know some people that say you
can't eat this and you can't eat that
and I say this watch me okay unless
you're gonna come by my house and stand
by my plate I might have a little
something okay sometime I might have me
a little cut a Hulk all right I might
have me a little basket uh or how I
might have me half a basket of Seale
Nuggets alright y'all don't tell me what
I can have and what I can't y'all never
know I might have a little bit of canary
brittle for I shut it down for a night I
might have some adolescent back ribs I
might bring a nine in the joint and have
a Popeye's chicken sandwich okay I might
have something rare I might have a
little bit of uh you know I might have
some Doberman on brioche or some carp
tarts or some gold fish fillets with a
little bit of a reindeer remoulade
drizzle everybody has different desires
so if you got a little bit of stretch
over there if you ladies drop you know
visiting another man and dropping off a
little bit of that freaking long neck Oh
meat to him well more power to land
brothers family you know what I hate the
most is when my sister drives past my
house and don't bring me it so thank you
for calling man and I hope everybody out
there drops off some rare meat to
somebody that they love
you know life is a gift and I believe
that man and uh and man I've been having
a tough time with it but that's okay
today is a new day and tomorrow's a new
day and sometimes man I don't mean I
know my day can be good and I don't even
want it to be I don't even want to make
it good you know sometimes I don't even
want to it's like I want to hold on to
the anger you know
I want to hold onto I just want it just
because if I do that then it gives me
it's like a don't you see I'm angry
something's wrong
I'm angry man it's just so it's so it's
hard to just say hey everything
everything's ok it's really if to really
trust the world like that
it's a journey man it is a journey you
guys thank you so much for being a part
of this past weekend as always you can
hit hit the hotline nine eight five six
six four nine five zero three calling
with what's going on with you column
with what isn't going on with you if you
have thoughts or reactions just
something we discussed today on here
Sharon you know if you know if you if
you haven't if you're in some pain man
share it up you know you know and we can
we can we keep we can beat it I believe
that we can beat it you guys be good to
yourselves man you deserve it you know
and I believe that I'm gonna go out a
kind of a somber tune but I'm feeling
sometime kind of somber you know and
that's okay I'm managing it in them and
it's organized some some barity and this
is Evan Bartels out of I believe
Nebraska I wanna say our could be out of
Missouri
man I hate that I have not remembered
that right now but uh a beautiful song
here the devil God and me
[Music]
mother may I open my
this is a great big world waiting right
outside
[Music]
mother Mary's my boy we the people have
that joy
mother Maris my head
though I did not try this
[Music]
mother may have slipped away though I
did not damn right you can come for me
Oh
[Laughter]
you can comfort me
[Music]
oh I do have your may stuck in my ear
down the plain though I beg you let me
be
[Music]
there will you know my plea the crown of
lies I wear insane
well I would give to Trekkie
[Music]
you can come for me
Evon Bartels
[Music]
day
but you can come with me
[Music]
the devil God and me
and check that out we will put the link
there on the YouTube Jesus man it's
powerful winner Jesus though I had my
face
[Music]
and will you cast man doubts away
take my sins down to the grave
[Music]
if there is holes and let me see
there is laughs those like me
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can come for me
keep going man if you got this man you
got this man long but you can't comfort
me
[Music]
you can come for me
Oh ha you can comfort me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
I'll conquer the
[Music]
something powerful man when that hit
your man there's some powerful in a song
you know it's like it can rearrange all
the pieces inside of you and make them
into something that that feels
completely different than where you were
at the beginning of it and that's
captivating man it's like a surgeon you
know it's like a construction worker man
music is I mean it's just non-invasive
surgery to just go Institute to get into
me man that song right there by heaven
man it gets into me mother may I rest my
head though I did not try my best man
and that right there I mean that's the
power of a mother of family you know
no matter what you do or how well you do
it that you were okay here that's uh you
know a love without judgment you know I
hope to be able to love that way one day
myself I think but and I'm not being
hard on myself I'm just thinking and I'm
just trying to think and feel and be
alive you know I want to get all the
fields out of this life if I can bro
gang [ __ ] dawg you guys be good man